que en Irlanda del Norte llegó a belfas
para asegurar el apoyo a su acuerdo de
ruptura del brexit algo que sus
predecesores no lograron conseguir
estoy encantado de que ayer logramos
avanzar en nuestras negociaciones con la
Unión Europea y que alcanzáramos un
acuerdo el nuevo marco de Windsor que
creo que es un paso extraordinario y
positivo para Irlanda del Norte y que
representa como lo dijo la propia
presidenta de la comisión europea un
paso histórico y una oportunidad para
avanzar y resolver algunos de los
problemas del pasado las mercancías
británicas destinadas únicamente a
Irlanda del Norte ya no necesitarán
controles aduaneros sino que utilizarán
un nuevo carril verde mientras que las
mercancías destinadas a la Unión Europea
utilizarán Un carril rojo la propuesta
ha sido bien recibida por muchos
diputados entre ellos el líder del
partido laborista
la propuesta del carril verde y rojo es
buena facilitará la vida de las empresas
permiti rá a los ciudadanos de Irlanda
del Norte participar más libremente en
la vida económica de Reino Unido tiene
todo nuestro apoyo
el líder del partido unionista
democrático honora Irlandés dijo que
aunque las propuestas abordan algunas de
las preocupaciones que causaron su
boicot sigue habiendo problemas entiendo
que cuando vendemos productos a la Unión
Europea por supuesto tenemos que cumplir
con las leyes de la Unión Europea eso
está claro pero qué ocurre cuando
comerciamos dentro del Reino Unido Creo
que este es el tipo de cuestiones y
preguntas que examinaremos detenidamente
a medida que leamos el texto legal aún
no es un hecho los diputados británicos
votarán las nuevas cláusulas para una
nueva provincia que lleva sin gobierno
autónomo desde febrero